- FUR SURE.
- HO-HO!
LOOKIN' STRAIGHT GRIZZLY.
- BITCH BETTER HAVE MY HONEY!
- OH. OOH. BEAR PUNS.
I LIKE THOSE.
- DUDE, I CAN'T BELIEVE
YOU SPENT YOUR ENTIRE PAYCHECK
ON THAT JACKET.
- WELL, I DIDN'T SPEND
MY ENTIRE PAYCHECK.
I MADE $350 AND CARL GAVE ME
A DEAL ON THE COAT.
$345.
- THAT'S GOOD.
THAT'S A GOOD DEAL.
- SO YOU SAVED FIVE BUCKS.
WAY TO GO.
- WELL, I INVESTED MY SAVINGS
IN A LITTLE BOTTLE OF IPECAC.
IT'S THE STUFF
THAT MAKES YOU BARF.
- SMART MOVE.
- BASICALLY
A GET-OUT-OF-WORK-FREE PASS.
- YEAH, IT MAKES YOU BARF,
DUDE.
'CAUSE NOTHING MAKES ME BARF.
IT'S WEIRD.
I'VE GOT A STOMACH OF STEEL.
- ADAM, SCIENTISTS
DEVELOPED THAT.
IT WOULD MAKE YOU VOMIT.
- BECAUSE SCIENTISTS MADE THIS.
- YEAH.
- WHO BELIEVES
IN SCIENTISTS, DUDE?
LET ME GIVE THIS
A LITTLE TESTEROO.
HMM. THAT'S WEIRD.
DEFINITELY DON'T FEEL
LIKE BARFING RIGHT NOW.
OH, WAIT. UGH!
NO, I'M BARFING.
UGH! I'M BARFING RIGHT NOW.
I'M NOT BARFING.
- OKAY.
- WAIT I'M BARFING.
UGH! I'M BARFING.
THOSE SCIENTISTS BETTER CHECK
THEIR HYPOTENUSES, DUDE.
OH, GOD.